silence moteur
ah non
l'équipe de tournage du jour s'est
Stanislas Gaspard ou encore romane tous
s'inscrit au cours de pratique
cinématographique dispensés au collège
Sainte-Thérèse de Rambouillet ils sont
10 au total et prépare une web série
appelée oklm avec leur professeur le
réalisateur Benjamin palier originaire
de Rambouillet c'est une série pour les
adolescents qui a été réalisé en gros
pour les adolescents pour parler des
problèmes que peuvent
rencontrer certains adolescents dans
leur scolarité
j'attends donc l'autre rôle principal
c'est Enola on est les deux personnages
de la série qui vont aller dans un kebab
raconter leurs problèmes aux autres
aux assistants aux assistants du kebab
qui tiennent le kebab donc on va leur
parler de nos problèmes ils vont nous
parler de choses qu'ils ont vécu en lien
avec ce problème et ils vont nous
apporter des solutions tenir la perche
vérifier l'enregistreur faire le clap ou
encore le making of sur le tournage tous
les élèves ont un poste qui change au
fil des prises un cours avec un
véritable intérêt pédagogique il permet
aux élèves de découvrir les différents
métiers du cinéma moi ce que je préfère
faire c'est le clap
pourquoi parce que c'est un peu le truc
l'image du cinéma enfin quand on tourne
sur les dessins animés sur on voit
toujours le clap je préfère faire
l'acteur parce que en fait j'aime
beaucoup je suis très à l'aise à l'oral
et j'aime beaucoup faire ce genre de
choses j'aime beaucoup incarner un
personnage c'est de voir la progression
et l'effort des autres par rapport à
quand on fait à la première prise et à
la dernière prise comprendre et voir le
rendu final tu dis waouh pour les films
on voit vraiment que les acteurs mais
que derrière il y a plein de monde pour
tout préparer séparation des parents
harcèlement ou encore stress la web
série abordent des sujets propres à
l'adolescence des thématiques que nos
cinéastes en herbe connaissent très bien
je fais une élève en cure de
désintoxication pour les jeux vidéo
parce que c'est un peu que je suis
addict aussi dans la vraie vie je trouve
que c'est très important d'en parler
parce qu'il y a il y a plein d'élèves
qui sont concernés et qui peuvent avoir
ces problèmes là c'est ce qui se passe
au collège
les amis et l'amour sujet principal au
collège ils sont contents qu'on parle
d'eux qu'on parle de toi de leurs
petites aventures du quotidien qu'on a
vécu nous aussi et donc même pour nous
il y a un côté nostalgique et donc c'est
toujours sympa
et Alexandre Gillet voit française de
Ryan Gosling font également partie du
casting la web série comprendra cet
épisode et devrait sortir au printemps
prochain